a mother is accused of killing her two
children and it turns out she was an
employee at a state agency meant to
protect children the i-team has obtained
evidence at the center of this case
manessa murphy is here with the story
joven trevino's job was to help families
but we've learned there was an
investigation into her family that was
shortly before police say she killed her
children my mother and my child killed
my son christopher fox on the phone with
a 9-1-1 operator on july 19. first he
found his four-year-old son christopher
then his one-year-old daughter gianna
but no sign of his fiancee jovin trevino
the children's mother and a department
of family services employee the mom told
me she was going to do it but she really
was henderson police say trevino drowned
the children and tried to take her own
life she was arrested the same day in
arizona the i-team obtained evidence at
the center of the case including a copy
of this note which detectives say
trevino left on her cell phone it reads
in part i'm sorry there is no way i
would walk off this earth and leave my
precious children behind also i was
facing a suspension or dismissal at work
meaning lose everything or near because
who's to say when i would have been
employed again according to clark county
trevino was a family services assistant
with dfs the job included helping
families apply for assistance and
monitoring visitations she was employed
with the county since july 2019.
according to this dfs document the
agency received a report alleging
neglect two days before the children's
lives were taken fox testified in front
of the grand jury a cps worker went to
the house that afternoon before he found
his children but nobody meaning trevino
answered the door in her note trevino
also refers to the stress of her
ex-relationship
to fox she writes i forgive you for
everything and will always love you the
i-team has learned there were
allegations of domestic violence against
fox he was previously ordered to stay
away from trevino he's accused of
violating the order of protection at
least twice the i-team reached out to
fox through his attorney he declined an
interview on the 9-1-1 call fox is heard
blaming himself for his children's
deaths i did this i
you did not do this i can't believe i
let this happen trevino is currently in
jail facing murder charges a county
spokesman says she was no longer
employed by dfs as of august 5th
vanessa murphy 8 news now
our channel 8 i-team requested an
interview with trevino and did not
receive a response says of air time